fifty-two players war zone raided 1867
average rating time handicapped here we
go let's roll let's not get made it even
though it might not count or anything oh
man look at this there's already the
time is already a bit off it's seen 27
minutes 30 seconds remaining I'm gonna
take that okay I might get pushed around
I want to go to squares let's make it
work with one Bishop c5 Knight here I
want to get to g3 let's see if they take
the knight they did Oh
Knight here that's brutal bishop here oh
man
it's very scary over here why did I let
that why'd I let that Knights it right
there that's brutal I want to get to
that b2 pun they take my pond let's take
this seven I got a pig huh are you
kidding me no way I'm beat I'm beat
I can't defend against this no come on
you could defend you could defend you
could defend is this gonna defend please
say it's going to please say this works
you could do it you could do it you can
do it no okay wait wait wait wait I
could take here I could take here if
Queen here I could take on f6 ah why
just move just move just anywhere oh I'm
a dead man
is this gonna work please say it works I
got a run for the hills oh it's very
scary I don't have any time I have no
time this is at least perpetual for
white at least they should try for more
definitely I don't have any time this is
a bad start I don't have any time oh my
good it's like what's the first game you
can't recover from that oh why did I let
that night Queen get so excited over my
king side their Knight f6 was deadly
okay don't you dare give up don't you
dare give up you can do it you can do it
oh man I've been through worse I've been
through worse I've definitely been
through worse you can do it
you have no quit in you yes I do
but I'm gonna pretend like I don't yes I
do but I'm gonna pretend like I don't
okay let's pretend let's pretend like I
have no quit in me let's take this pond
beyond the night tricky stuff everywhere
tricky tricky tricky stuff check drop
the sea pond it's gonna be okay pinpoint
the c-7 pond and take that pond take
that pond you know you want to take them
if h5 I'm not taking that pond okay here
we go c7 c7 grab this and then it leads
to main rook to c8
rook c8 leads to me just capture I need
a quick boost I need to get back to zero
before I can move forward I'm at zero
yes zero whoa let's go here minty Wow
Knight f6 I'm having flashbacks again of
that Knight f6
Wow Knight f6 made me chew up I think 20
seconds there's no save oh man that was
equivalent to resigning right there that
how much time I invested ah brutal
brutal oh that was a slip-up right there
by the Minster oh oh the Queen is hit
are they gonna resign I need a quick
resigner pins take a rope take a pawn
give a check
bring out the Queen hit a knight can't
resign right here I get the rook unless
they block where is this mean man one
threat they resigned back to term at
four four four six I'm in 12th Blitz
star okay we don't want a French I
almost just dropped a piece right there
oh okay the Queen's ready to be trapped
queenside castle okay I got it I got it
engaged
oh they defended I was gonna
fishing-pole them let's try this
I get that file open up okay this is a
four core I have this right here I wanna
get in h6 and still try it secure my
bishops position and I don't want this
night to hit me either
let's come over here I should probably
just be doubling up when I get that pond
a little scary over here a little scary
come over here Knight has me a bit
nervous I want to get pigs here pigs
pigs pigs ooh this is scary
that's not pigs uh night check I got to
get rid of that night he can't be
tolerated I'll get rid of that night
okay
pigs
pigs one Pig more pigs right around the
corner making three one two three one
two three back to chairman ten
somebody's twenty guess who
twenty twelve twelve you can't come back
after losing your first game who are you
you can't do that who do you think you
are who do you think you are thinking
you could come back after a silly loss
from round one okay get ready to be
kicked around get ready
throw a rock on see a kill the night go
to c4 c4 is juicy the bishop went here
c4 is hit if Bishop back ago Knight a5
to this square
okay Knight c4 is still on the cards
okay no it's not
the knight is not protected though okay
let's get castled I want to break in the
center let's hit this bishop break in
the center my Knights dead no it's not
it should have been
come over here dark square weaknesses
where are you
what are you dark square weaknesses
where are you pawn push my bishop wants
to see the world he wants to see I just
drop stuff oh this is dead this is very
very dangerous
oh look at how far that pond just got
he's very scary come here save the day
Bishop pawn push is probably good I'm
having flashbacks to that last game
where this part got down here oh very
scary
oh man this is brutal
this is brutal oh I'm on this pond I've
missed that
I think f6 is still good if pawn push I
don't take the pawn let's just trade
Queens before it's too late
please please get the Queen's off that's
all I ask
let's get the Queens off I didn't do
anything wrong okay I could take that
pawn but I just want to make sure I'm
aided I thought for a second there might
have been an
move that would give me that's not the
case run over here King you have nothing
to fear now do you
it's defend upon I dropped upon no no no
let's just drop the rope that's okay
there's no time left for white wow it's
still scary
okay time burnin that was actually a
really bad time burning to go with okay
I did it though I did it haven't got
away with it thirty thirty twenty twenty
eighteen there's a lot of guys up there
this guy's one of them now he's got ten
but he's a 2,300 player okay it's
hitting out of this Knight f3 whoa whoa
there goes upon you could do it you
could do it you could do it
it's guard here come back here grab a
knight what's the you know I'm down upon
my Knights getting kicked away I'm
losing another pun ah I just dropped a
knight no I didn't oh this is so bad
this is so bad what am i doing come on
get something do something even if it's
wrong give a check give a check if the
King goes there hit of rook hit a rock
hit a rock hit her up pin a knight give
a check over here and then mate mate
mate mate mate go in the corner you know
you wanted to go in the corner you know
you want to go in the corner you know
you want to go in the corner you didn't
want to go in the corner ah pin them up
pin him up pin him up pick him up pick
him up over here my bishops dead they're
still in a pickle now they're not get
that bishop the bishops gonna get my
pawn to open this up and okay can I get
this 21 seconds they have is this
working check I got this not quite not
quite not quite sneaky stuff everywhere
Bishop's open position Oh getting
deflected oh I gotta win this time
burners I need time burners give a check
anything
I'm getting flushed around there's no
time there's no time wait I'm a check
ah they got my rook no they don't have
any time
I'm down at time by a mile 5.1 seconds
yeah you can't come back if you lost -
oh the wind is knocked right out of me
right out of me ah
I need seven resigner 'he's in a row
where are you calling no resigner x' oh
no no no no no no no no no no I really
don't mean that by the way I just can't
help but just say it though I don't mean
if you don't mean it why are you saying
it then like it here right now why are
you saying that if you don't mean it I'm
gonna take such a beating I'm gonna take
such a beating on the e-file you have no
idea
here comes the beginning of it the
beginning of a serious beating of a
serious serious beating Oh rook takes
Knight everybody loves a pin rook Queen
check
get out of there rook I'm dropping
pieces I'm playing on tilt
where are the poker players you know
what I'm talking about don't take that
okay oh man
this is very scary I can't even move my
pieces oh I can't even move them I got
to do this as dangerous as it looks as
dangerous as it looks very oh I just
take a knight it's a free night okay
take him now Wow take free pieces he's a
passed pawn and he's going for a
touchdown he's going for TD he's going
gone for six but not so fast there's
still time to drop pizzas oh man back to
tournament land 2672 fifty six thirty
thirty oh man talk about taking the wind
right out of my sails they're long gone
whoa sneakiness right around every
corner ready get my queen
no they know I'm having a rough
tournament there like he's never gonna
suspect this one never in a million
years would he suspect that I go after
his queen in one move
get out of there Queen I cannot deal
with you
get out of there Knight although that
power can be taken Oh watch out for
tricky mates
let's go Knight let's go over look on f1
I have that secured don't I f7 I don't
want to take f7 just yet now I do it's
me yes that's why I needed thirty-eight
I'm in fourth 15 minutes and change a
couple speed bumps a couple big speed
bumps no I'm in fifth I'm in fifth you
can do it you can do it don't you dare
give up is this the guy that gave me a
beating earlier I need to give them a
beating back can I do that hit him hit
him hit him hit him I just sounded like
a cornerman right there hit him hit him
with the uppercut watch out watch out
get to c3 oh I just dropped a piece
again whoa don't turn away there's
pieces falling and every move every move
there's gonna be pieces hanging whoa we
got made threats and stuff
counter-attack
I got a defend like this if my knight is
hit okay I'll have to worry about the
bishop let's get over here let's back up
whoa
Penn ruski get out of pins I'm on the
night at the end of this maybe I'm a
knight twice okay I think the the coast
is clear
clock situation whoa it's coming back to
a protected square let's just straight
Queens before I drop pieces before I
drop my queen with just exchange Queens
could we we just exchanged Queens here
what I do what I do to deserve this can
we try again
let's try it one more time right here
this is a good one to try it on isn't it
okay we'll try it back again I'm b4
let's trade it try it again
ah now we trade let's trade these guys
let's hit her up f4 is gonna be played
but I got to come back here I think
night here would have been good
oh I just dropped my rook I got a pre
move this is horrible horrible horrible
miss take this pawn come on you could do
it you could do it you could do it you
could do it seven seconds I got a time
burn again pieces falling everywhere
everywhere I can't even move well right
here we can't even move they're right
here pawn push they're down on time
they're dead nothing
Oh barely barely barely 52 wow what an
ugly ugly ugly tournament Wow
I need to just trade pieces before I
hang them that is the plan that's a good
strategy to pieces just trade them train
them before you hang them okay h3 it's
been this night he's too much of a
bother I think I don't want to come in
here that caused trouble no causing
trouble
okay develop castle let's take this guy
clean up castle pawn push in the center
not so fast let's trade off bishops okay
I could go at the Queen good to have one
oh man this is a tough pin let's get out
of it I can't get out of it and give a
check with my queen and then run away
right okay
night here if g4 otherwise I get the H
file can't let me exchange these pawns
the rooks gonna get here uh-oh uh-oh
maintenance threat pawn takes pawn rook
h8 you're gonna do that rook takes h6
otherwise hangout bishop hang on
come on what do we have what's nice is
that even if I drop a piece in this
position I'm just gonna take care
anything even though I'm dropping my
queen anything it doesn't matter any
move any move any move no time back
determined 68 140 140 90-68 I'm trying
for second can I get second 2100 ah the
2107 a with me so far in these
tournaments or this tournament let's go
in FF 4 oh no no no no no no Bishop f4
might be played not so fast with your
premium of silly don't be silly
oh boy oh boy pawn here right here ok
they stop that I get d5 in f5 is gonna
be played isn't it let's get it and get
that night out of there pushing the
center when that's gonna have to run
away pawn push I take this guy get more
push up here more pushes more pushes ok
let's I get to this square let's push
this even though I'm dropping upon ok I
just want to may have a target over here
on the Queen side we'll take that no
okay let me get here pawn push again now
ok c4 no beast b2 oh boy no no no no no
oh it's a little scary over here it's
definitely a little scary whoa whoa whoa
whoa
whoa I feel like I'm getting made it am
I getting made it please say no man
please say it's gonna be okay run over
here King run over where right here run
over on the queenside clear the way my
king is coming let's go here I want to
keep this structure okay my Knights here
to defend stuff I feel a little bit more
comfortable just a little bit my Knights
gonna come over here just to reinforce
stuff reinforce that stuff over here
right here my king is gonna flee run it
for the hills running for the hills
watch over this pawn get my king up
where right here right here and then
right here to defend and now my Knights
can start jumping in barely barely able
to defend now that pond is falling I'm
just gonna take it take it again and
then just hope for the best right here
just take here even though it's dropping
don't fall for me whoa dad almost felt
like me that almost felt like me they
have no time 8601 40 that is a big one
right there that is a big one to
overcome right there I don't know about
that okay well you could do it you could
do you could get top three is it
possibly get top three you notice how
I'm slowly uh going down here I said top
maybe I could get second and then just a
little while later third what's next
what's next fourth all right let's go I
don't even I thought I might clean was
ready to recapture on that square oh man
okay it's been to [ __ ] and deflected
here let's get back over here I want to
get this
clean up we're clean 2g4 pond push just
take the pine it's a mating - making one
- just move move move move move move
move
are they gonna move back - chairman they
resigned 2200 140 110 106 can I get
third come on I think I have black
against this guy every time and he knows
exactly what I'm gonna be going for
somebody else to ask this guy do you
ever get sick of it okay right there
he's saying stop with your nonsense stop
it right now
stop eying the h2 square you silly goose
you silly goose you okay let's get
Castle just play maybe a bit regular
regular opposed to your other silliness
okay let's come here preparing knight in
the center okay let's do this don't drop
stuff that Bishop around play here and
then I can get my knight to eat free or
d3 pawn push in the center my Knights
gonna get kicked away I think ah thirty
seconds my bishop you get kicked away
it's come here because I want to pivot
on this square or something right here
Queen trade otherwise you get material
or something
if the bishop blocks that my nightstands
a really well let's come back what is my
queen even doing here okay opposite
colored bishops get rid of that guy and
let's come over here I don't my king to
run out there to try this and watch out
for the pigs let's trade one of them off
I'm dropping my pawn okay down the of 11
seconds pawn push seems to be pretty
good I gotta try this King position next
King position King position I want to
switch roles have my King defend against
that pod come over here King up to this
Square
position give a check grab a pond grab
another pond give a check time burners
time burners gonna take my pond to give
a check more time burners anything just
move move move
ok the download time 1:26 I'm in 3rd 181
26 I'm just trying to hold 3rd I think
that's the most reasonable Jonathan cm
double the points
efore ok d4 back to tournament quick
resigner 180 146 5 minutes and change ok
Almaguer al legato is al gonna move al
is going to move four minutes and change
for the points have been doubled open
Sicilian yet again an accelerated
version of this it allows for night
there but that's that's parried
it's parried let's go with b6 if I do b5
then there's a 4 I should have no I
can't do that right away making once
right easy to miss easy to miss easy to
miss g3 or h3 which one okay that's the
better one light-square weaknesses
though Oh Forks this is a full rook up I
have a full rack of
man just pawn push queenside castle
watch out for mates over here that
happened earlier avoid that Bishop check
pawn push Oh kick that night away kick
that night away and then what hit this
knight again bishop here looking for me
okay pawn push right here I think I want
I really don't want to take that night
on push I want to get at this point
there it is I got the Queen this is main
million one and then two right here
back to chairman 166 to 4200 166 143
minutes left just trying to hold on the
third for dear life
oh this guy I think might have been the
one who beat me in between our variation
no we're not having this so this is a
French a French coming out and okay
maybe I should have done Knight f4 moves
sooner I'm on this point how will be
defended
let's come here pawn push is happening I
think real soon all I get this pawn if
that happens to be careful that I want
to take the knight if there's a pressure
here or let's come back take like this
and then get my other look right here a
five let's take this come here so I
could play f3 to kick this night away
and I have this Square to hit the bishop
okay so this is getting all fancy here
Oh Forks they might be signed this is a
four come up a rook clean right here
no I'm dropping rook if I do that don't
you dare start dropping stuff now get
out of there it's a triple out triple
trouble this Queen is it making me a
little bit nervous here okay the Queen
I'm on the Queen and resigned they're
not resigning time burner they wanted a
draw I don't want to drive back
determine 186 I could get maybe second
140 good that is that guy gonna lose one
137 137 I
Needham I have to win in 30 seconds I
can't let more than 30 seconds come off
my clock pin this night get this up pawn
push should take care anything don't
lose him with 0.3 seconds on your clock
whatever you do don't lose with 0.3
seconds on your clock when when I have
to hope that that guy doesn't win or he
loses or something I'm on this square
okay I'm on the bishop with check I'm on
the night as well
pawn push right here okay what's um
what's happening here I'm on the Queen
Oh 50 seconds remaining they resigned
back to term at 206 I'm in second I'm in
second to 260 206 42 seconds that guy
might be ready to win I have to try for
something sneaky here sneaky just to
secure second place after this start
can I get second I think it's secured
that I would get a third I think it's
gonna be a pin keep a check
okay
what's that moving into oh that's that's
actually okay ten seconds I can't I
can't get anything here there's no time
there's just no time
oh I just mouse slipped what I get what
I get what I get I got second take
second place sector of all that oh what
a disaster
oh man far off from first but what can
you expect if you have two losses right
there ah man good games all 19 out of 19
is fantastic